hey
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily daily videos
you guys already know if you have
watched two or more of my lives and you
do not subscribe we have beef okay beef
people it is not cool this is not cool
so we have a couple announcements i know
we've gone through these all so we can
get monetized on that one too so go
subscribe to the channel we also have a
new facebook page and a new twitch page
on top of that guys the chat is members
only today so we have three tiers of
memberships and next week we are going
to have a members only live stream so
all members on wednesday will get to
have pizza with me jess and ish after
the show ask us some questions get some
behind the scenes look so if you want to
be a part of that
sign up for our memberships it's only
like five bucks a month come on y'all um
okay also
my instagram is just.purlything so make
sure you go follow that we're trying to
get to 30k on instagram
um we're also trying to get to 250k on
youtube so subscribe to the channel
though not too quick what i said not too
close oh yeah yeah we got it we got a
members we got a 24
we have a 24 live stream at 2 50. so you
know what you actually don't need to
subscribe slow watch them subscribe
quicker no no no
we're good
anyways um and also guys we have a
member of the week who's our member of
the week jess remember of the week is
chris chris has been donating and giving
to the channel a lot this week and just
in previous weeks and then last night he
even came onto another show that pearl
was on and gave in that so he was a
super fan this week so shout out to you
chris yeah member of the week yeah
okay so today i have a lovely panel i
got some people that have been before
some people that are new so why don't we
go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact you can start oh fun facts daily 26
one half of the domino effect podcast
i'm taken
and
fun fact oh this is a tough one
um
i've given my phone fat before
i lost my virginia log
have you said that before yeah i said
that before oh wow yeah on a log yeah
how'd that go for you
i mean it's easy to dog you know because
it's like a big bit of support in it
yeah that was going to be my friction
friction from the bottom splinters
[Laughter]
my name's louise i'm 33
what were the other things
your name your age your relationship
status single
um
oh fun fact
i didn't prepare
i don't know
do you have it do you have a pet i don't
know i don't know
i have a daughter she's kind of like a
pet okay
how old how old is she she's 15. okay
go ahead um my name is iman i'm 21 i'm
single
a fun fact uh
maybe i
i always look for my glasses when i'm
having them on is that fun
i always look for my glasses when i
actually when i'm actually wearing them
speaking to the mic oh sorry
so yeah that's it
okay my name's daniel i'm 25
i'm single
fun fact um i was left-handed as a kid
but because i went to a catholic school
they trained me to be
right-handed
oh that's that is interesting can you
can you still use both
yeah
kind of that's talent
where's you hey guys i'm jessica i am 28
years old and i'm single and my fun fact
is yo hablo espanol
i speak spanish nice are you fluent no
not yet i should be i should be pretty
sad that i'm not but why is it sad you
know you've been studying it for a while
yes for a long time i did it in high
school and then i've been in
like three different spanish-speaking
countries throughout my life and wow so
i'm not fluent okay i didn't even i was
like i don't even know that no figure
out espanola
so um today's topic is what do we title
this video oh when the past haunts you
and the reason
the reason um that i brought this up is
because
who who's aware of the sierra and future
and russell wilson dynamic yeah
vaguely okay so for those that don't
know
when sierra was in her 20s she dated a
lot of bad boys
one of those being future
and she has a kid with future
that doesn't work out because he i mean
it's future yeah
i don't know what you thought
he he cheats on her right and so then he
she they break up whatever she ends up
marrying russell wilson
and her and russell wilson have like
what three four like about two i don't
know
two they have two more kids total
so
essentially
russell wilson is like the quote-unquote
good guy
but
the problem is now
in a way the past haunts her because
everyone always makes fun of russell
wilson for like being with her because
she had a kid with a future
and
recently future decided to release a
song
i wanted to put the music video on the
stream guys but
i'm afraid that youtube's gonna take it
down so i was just like i'm not gonna
play with it so the link to the video is
actually in the description but i'm
gonna read some of the lyrics
so
could this thing be more you could never
this could be yours if it's really meant
to be baby baby because i'm interested
baby baby
you tell me you're falling out of love
with me hope you can find someone to
love you better than i did also
during the video
he damn near had a picture of russell
wilson it wasn't actually him but it was
a football player yeah it was like a
football player and yeah i don't
take our memories on love and treating
it like nothing take it in our memories
on love and treatment like gossip it's
love for my grandmother make me gentle
when i care for you tell me you're
falling out of love with me it's
breaking my heart in two i just don't
want to sit and pray baby i almost love
it's almost like
i almost like it didn't happen to make
you happy you're telling me you're
falling out of love with me hope you can
find someone to love you better than i
did you ain't you telling me you're
falling out of love with me hope you can
find someone to love you better than i
did could this thing be more you tell me
you're falling out of love with me it's
my love for my grandmother makes me
gentle when i care for you and it's
actually a catchy song it's like you're
falling out of love with me
if it's really meant to be baby because
i'm interested
so he's basically shooting a shot with
sierra
after
so the question is should men date women
that have a bad boy past
oh that's a question
if you're brave enough
why not
you're stupid enough
[Laughter]
go on
if you're stupid enough then yeah go for
it like but no not more so than anything
date who you want more so you just
understand that there are consequences
for dating
women that have chosen to make those
decisions
and if you're able to live with the
consequences
kudos to you but more so you should
understand that you won't like the
repercussions of what
is going to come out of that i guess it
depends on if they've healed or not yeah
like
absolutely
probably i was just about to say you can
have a bad boy face because you're going
through something maybe you're young
you've got issues
people mature people grow and women grow
they change
yeah but the problem is
this is this is the issue that a lot of
men find themselves in is the girls
really wanted the bad boys
they just accepted the
the nice guy because they couldn't lock
the bad boy down
and really
that's who they want to be with
is it
or is it just
maybe you have trauma and this person
that treats you like [ __ ] you're like oh
i'm so attracted to him but it's because
your father was disapproving of you and
so you want this person that rejects you
that's a very specific oh
i mean i don't know
well i think women are attracted to
traits like they call it the dark triad
trait so women are attracted to traits
that are like negative about guys
because they're also positive like the
guy like why why why do we date guys
that punch holes in the wall
it's because the same guy that is super
aggressive like maybe towards us and
just in general can also protect us
yeah okay so yeah yeah so it's like a
double the same guy that treats you like
[ __ ] it shows that he thinks highly of
himself because he can stand up for
himself
okay
and so what a lot of guys find they said
20 to 25 of marriages are sexless
and typically it's the woman holding out
like guys want to have sex
yeah but is that because she's repressed
because women are either demonized for
being
sexual or they're taught
hydrosexuality you need to be more than
that right i think they're presenting
their marriage yeah yeah but why why are
they repressed sexually but how why
would you be repressing their marriage
because you're supposed to consummate
and consummate because you could be
brought up in a family where
sex is very
taboo and as a woman you either you need
to be
more than pretty but i feel like but
even in like say we take the catholic
church or islam once you get married
you're supposed to be chop chop chop
chop contraception so i don't really
understand that one yeah every day
the message is always like wait till
marriage i feel like it's not
they're not like don't have sex but it's
also like
don't be sexual outside of marriage and
if you grow up with someone saying like
cover yourself up oh don't put yourself
on display don't don't express yourself
in that way
we think all of a sudden when you're
married you're going to be like oh i'm
this wild
sensual woman no i think it could be
yeah
could i say nobody gets married quicker
than two horny muslims or two
because you wanna go and do the job that
you've been suppressed okay yeah i don't
think women are suppressed in society at
all i think we're actually rewarded for
being sexual i mean you get more
followers on instagram you get more dms
you get you can make money on only fans
and even when people try to shame women
and say hey that's that's hoe behavior
they're they're they say slut-shaming so
they'll shame men for shaming women
okay so i don't really think women are
you know but then even if you are
in on instagram or or being
whatever you're slut-shamed or whatever
you're doing
just because someone is doing that to
you doesn't mean that you are then more
likely to get married
what do you mean so if you're very
promiscuous and open about it
are you going to be married that's true
you're correct probably not women that
tend to be married perhaps are more
traditional
and would
hide their sexuality be a bit more
convert and and
portray this image of like
purity yes
yes
yeah
especially depends on the environment
that you're in as well your background
your culture everything has a factor on
that as well
yeah
i feel like that would also like that
kind of home training would also be
associated with being like submissive to
your husband
so then the sexual side would come into
it when he initiates it but that doesn't
mean you feel comfortable in your
sexuality he might want to go all the
time and you haven't learned to express
you are if it's the right guy you wanna
you won't have sex all the time every
girl has had a guy that she wants to
have sex all the time i mean that's the
one you married no i know but that's the
point that's why that's why like that's
the whole point is because because
you're marrying yeah because you're
marrying the guy that you're not that
attracted to and so like basically the
more partners a woman has the less
likely she is to have a happy marriage
so if someone has a bad boy past like
she's less likely to be satisfied in her
marriage because if you're a virgin when
you get married you have an 80 chance of
getting into a happy marriage after 10
years if you have had sex with more than
five people which i think most men pray
for nowadays
and
um
it drops down to 25 percent okay and so
i think that's why historically we've
always protected women and like tell
them to like not be sexual outside of
marriage because the bond like the bond
is so strong for women during sex we
release a hormone during sex that men
don't
oxytocin yeah and the more you have sex
with people the less you release it's
like a defense mechanism basically yeah
that's interesting
and it all comes to that bondage you're
saying of uh the person that you
marry you might not actually be
satisfied satisfied with sexually
oxytocin is only released when you
actually come so if you're with a guy he
doesn't make you come you're not going
to have that bond your husband
[Music]
what if it happens
again your husband what if it happens
what if he
if he doesn't get you there well why
would you let's say
you're not talking about anyone
but say why would you ever marry someone
like that because you're a virgin and
it's
well if you're a virgin if you're a
virgin you don't know different i hear
it so like how would you know the sex is
bad if you're a virgin i hate that
and some girls don't have the option
like you can't have everything in a
guide so when do they realize that [ __ ]
or did they just go on thinking [ __ ]
their whole life what do you well i
think i mean the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31. yeah it makes
sense so i want to be a vegetarian no
yeah so it's like those those girls i
mean they've obviously if they start
having sex at 16
like one a year that's like at least 12
13 right yeah they've done a med team
yeah and so and so it's like
i mean you can't have everything and i
think when you time's running out you
got to pick what you want so some girls
are going to marry the guy they're not
attracted to but the problem is the guys
don't know that
because he thinks that as men our
insecurities we always want
a woman that's
more attractive than us so we think oh
yeah we've hit the jackpot really and
truly you're like hers like 10th pick or
the 100th pick
when that's your primary number one and
you've worked his whole life like no one
ever liked you and you worked your whole
life to become an accountant and you've
got a qualified accountant worked for 10
years
and you finally got someone sloppy
seconds and you're so happy but she's
sloppy at the end of the day
it's a life story oh my god
yeah my log story is from like 13 don't
worry about it
13. yes
yeah
oh my god that's nice where did you find
the logo
in the park i couldn't go i couldn't go
to my house they thought i was still
playing like ps1 in it you should have
been make sure you're speaking into the
mic speaking to the mic yeah doggy on
the logi like i can't believe the last
lyrics of the song because i'm
interested baby
and that's that
no but he's not shooting she's trying to
wind up winding up though it's obviously
the whole thing of him doing perfect
families taking his son out and now he's
just trying to be like you know what let
me just ruin someone's day today no so
in the music video the guy that was like
on the billboard and the girl with the
curly hair that's supposed to be sierra
and russell wilson yeah that's what i'm
saying okay but he's trying to see oh
you lot are doing perfect families
let me just [ __ ] up your day yeah like
your family's not so perfect i'm just
going to wind you up yeah it's just like
i don't know if amanda had ever done
this year if there's a girl that used to
chop
and you know she was mad onto you here
and you see out with our boyfriend you
might just do something antagonizing
just to be a preacher
i know females
why are you laughing
i expect it better i feel like i feel
like drake has a lyric like that where
he said he could tell that she had
[ __ ] the guy just because of the way
he hugged her yeah exactly so you'll do
that the way you grab him and grab her
waist like yeah you know what time it
was and he'll be looking like
what where you just do that that's like
it's like a dick measuring contest like
my dick is bigger than yours and you're
slapping on the table so you're having
like a [ __ ] off like yeah come on then
my cock's bigger is this is that what
you do i'm just saying from my friend i
heard oh
[Laughter]
i agree with the person i agree i said
it still
see men will do like subtle things women
will actually
be
out there with it like if someone if you
see your x-man with the next girl and
they're sitting at a dinner or whatever
you'll go up and talk to them like hey
so-and-so like crazy woman not all women
but the women that want drama and want
the to stir the pot they'll do that men
will do certain things like that like
put their hand around their back leave
it long there for a second and then they
were like all right i'll see you later
and the girl be like okay bye and i'm
like who's that oh no it's just a friend
plausible deniability but that's why my
advice to women if you see a guy that
used to deal with face front and just
move like you don't know the guy because
you end up in compromising situations
okay so a stat that
me and jess looked up before the show yo
crazy
is 60 of men and women have thought
about an x during sex yeah that's
madness
crazy that's rude did you just put your
hand up as if you've done that no i was
gonna say
[Laughter]
so knowing that do you think that men
should date women with lower body counts
how would that impact it though because
what if it's just one guy and the guy
was slapping the brakes off him was
doing a madness
i'm asking you
um
now i think that really has a bearing
you don't think body count matters no i
think body counts matters but i don't
think that has a bearing of whether
she's going to think about it because
she's going to think about it she's not
satisfied so it's more about are you
throwing it down like you should
yeah but the more people she slept with
the less likely like if she's like
no if she's slept with 50 dudes you
think you're going to be the best out of
50 dudes but the thing is obviously i
hope so she has to hold back
in my previous life out of 50. i'd
experience
i'd experience slinging my weedy around
and doing my nightstands but it's not
actually good sex and it doesn't make
good at sex
like you probably have the most
enjoyable sex when it's with one person
i'd say
so it all depends it really it comes
down to
you have to be super accountable and
look at yourself and just like
do i have magic fingers or am i mr
flashes like am i doing what i need to
do yeah really and truly that's that's a
very blue pill ideology that's like men
need to step up no i think well
if you can say it's pretty pill but it's
just like yeah the reality is if me as a
man
i can't make my woman be able to think
about just me yeah then well but why
wouldn't you pick a girl that you don't
have to deal with that baggage oh yeah
100 yeah 100 but what i'm saying is even
if you're saying that baggage but say
even if she slept with control like what
if
the size is just different and you can't
control yeah but then then it comes to
accountability if i pick the wrong one
like you need to pick the one for you
and if if she's not satisfied by me
there's signs you know when a girl wants
to sleep with you and knows if you're
the one or not so really it comes down
to
why am i experiencing just squeezing
this baby i i think that most girls can
pull one over on a guy i think most guys
think they're smarter than they are in
my opinion like i think
only the only people that really know is
her close friends
where you fall yeah i i agree with you
on that one yeah because i've seen it
where like i've seen a girl
like a guy
or so what somewhat like a guy
and then
when i've seen her with another guy that
she really likes her behavior her
mannerisms she won't even come up and
say hi to
guy friends that she she will like act
accordingly and i'm like
okay so this is what it looks like when
she really likes someone and that's when
i changed the game for me like a red
pill moment
because even
i i think most girls can trick a guy
into like thinking
yeah yeah
like and i always tell this story so
there was a girl that i knew in college
i might have you might have heard this
already
but so there's a girl i knew in college
and basically her freshman year at
college she dated the bad boy right
senior year she's dating the nice guy
man bought her a house
he bought a house yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah well just vibes just yeah i mean i
just think it was like the next step
they've been dating a little bit because
remember this is like three four years
later right
so you know she'd been dating him for a
minute no ring no not just house
i didn't i didn't i mean there were 21 i
don't know i just know
she and him
moved into a house
and
i'm at a party my my senior year of
college and i see her walk out of the
bathroom
with the guy from freshman year it
happens
and it was crazy because an hour later
the new guy shows up i feel bad for him
yeah and so that's why
i i say the girl the guy that she
complains about
like that's the one that got her
there's the saying after god fear eve
because women can actually just
lie to you like that i don't i can't
believe
he wouldn't notice anything i mean so at
all like any of that behavior no i think
i think women cheat more effectively
see if amanda amanda and cheap mandem
are sloppy but you see a woman the way
she'll cheat yeah you won't even believe
like it's
ever possible that's scary
what's that okay and jess have you ever
seen a girl cheat yeah
what's the craziest thing you've seen
someone cheat
hmm
i'm trying to think
what is the what is the craziest um
oh i had a friend who was dating a dude
and she had another dude asking
to
fly her out and fly her out to another
state go hang out with him dinner
everything and she was contemplating it
and i'm like
if you're in this relationship with the
dude she's like i think i'm gonna do it
and i was like okay
all right that's that's your choice you
know it's bad like you're in a
relationship with a dude but you're
gonna get flown out by this guy she's
like oh we're not gonna do anything i
was like all right
i'm just gonna go have a dinner and then
go back to an airbnb and chill she's
like i think i'm gonna do it i was like
okay
have you guys ever seen a girl cheat
not really no
loads of times
like loads of times like with you
[Laughter]
you know you know what the the funniest
thing is guys will tell me they'll be
like the i didn't realize how how bad
women were until i was the guy she
cheated with yeah because like mandom
used to turn it into a game like growing
up it was people like oh like you know
the whole mr stewie or girl like stuff
like that yeah i remember a person who
remained nameless
they were out
and then
they secured the girl on the night out
or the lady i should say
and gone to the car
she's glugging him off doing the throat
go business in the car
um
the husband's called it's just like i'll
pick you up
she's finished off
the guy and she's got and picked up by a
matey wow and she drove home she's happy
satisfied
this is crazy
oh my god women are
that's interesting do you think man
cheat as bad
not as bad because men are sloppy like
if your man's cheating you probably know
that's bad deep down you probably know
that he's cheating yeah that women
always have a hunch exactly i would
agree with that yeah would you would you
guys be willing to share a guy
if if he had everything you wanted he
loved you
but just now and then he would step out
just
arrives look at it look at it
man me and jess are on a two-for-one
special
get it while you can yeah sister wives
would you actually do that
no
no no
you might i might okay why tell me why i
don't
i think monogamy is very hard
i think long term man and women or so
would you took an open relationship are
you talking about on his end
um
it would have to be both oh it would
have to be oh
yeah it would have to be so we're still
love sorry to cut you over
could you still because a lot a man
we've had the conversation before a man
can love a woman and throws willie
around and fall into vagina from time to
time but a lot of women they can't do
that so would you could you say that you
could still love the guy you're with and
still be open in a relationship in my
mind
i think after a certain amount of years
5 10 maybe 20 years yes
in the beginning early phases i don't
think
i could because that possessive like
need to claim is there but i think
eventually i imagine this is how i
imagine after time
i probably could
i would probably be a bit bored i
imagine he would too would you be
willing to do it where it's it's open on
his end but not yours no i feel like
that's what the terms would usually be
if he's providing and stuff like that
yeah if he's providing okay so if he's
thinking how many relationships are like
just the man providing
no but this is isn't that the scenario
you presented oh yeah yeah yeah so he's
if he's providing well then yeah i'd
probably have to put up with it but yeah
you're like see no evil here
as long as he pays the bills around when
i need you to brush your teeth when you
get in yeah because um 8 000 fun fact 8
000 years ago 17 women reproduced for
every one man
yeah so we can't we can't undo biology
8 000 years ago 17 women reproduced for
every one man that's a football team in
the suburbs wow so then did demand to go
back in time but now
with the population getting so out of
control surely it would make sense to
reverse that so so so actually there's
there's um
there's probably going to be problems in
society because of population decline
actually people aren't having kids
why because okay think about it um
if you don't have enough people in the
next generation to fill jobs
then that leaves a gap in society
what jobs are not being filled well
right now um i want to say the medical
industry is low on like doctors and i
don't know specifically i just know that
one of the biggest like causes of
civilizations like collapsing is a
population decline
when you think about yeah like
overpopulation is good for an economy
yeah when you look at um japan because
they've got an aging population they've
got to a point of because they've got um
less young staff coming in to work
they've got state funded uh fueled
pensions but there's so many pensioners
and there's not enough workforce oh okay
so you've just got a lot of people
living on the state and not enough
people paying into the state
so why are young people not going into
the workplace what is that no just
people don't have having kids anymore
yeah why they're not having kids they
can't afford it they don't
so um i would say it's because of
hypergamy do you know what hypergamy is
so hypergamy is the action of marrying
or forming a sexual relationship with a
person of a superior sociological or
educational background women date across
and up hierarchies
so essentially when birth control was
introduced it gave women the option to
sleep around
so when that happened basically a
smaller and smaller percentage of men
were sleeping with all the girls so if
you ask a hundred percent of women what
they want in a guy they list 20 percent
of men sometimes less so if you want a
guy that's over six foot that's only 15
percent of guys
you want to be good looking cut it in
half you want them to make money cut
that in half right
so basically when that happened um i
think it let fours fives and sixes in
terms of like looks sleep with guys that
are eights nines and tens and think
they're on that level and then think
anything below it is settling
okay
so as women's rights and freedom have
progressed relationships have regressed
yes
so
yeah yeah we need to either
step down
how do we get out of this
everyone needs to start having children
yeah okay i mean i think it's just
like we're just in a society where women
a lot of women are delusional okay
because what's your level right anyone's
like level one to ten it's what you can
get to commit to you it's not what you
can sleep with
and i think a lot of times women like
confuse the two
and so they'll they'll [ __ ] on average
men
like that's why we have in society we
have
i don't want no scrub like
[Laughter]
but we don't have i don't want no whales
i don't want no fat chicks like like
they would be canceled immediately
and so everything in society it's weird
once you see it you can't unsee it it's
like everything in society is empowering
women and pushing women forward and so
it it makes us narcissistic almost
because we think the whole world
revolves around us
but the same thing of what empowers you
also makes you blind because even though
you think you're being empowered but
then when you're not getting wifed by
the man that you want and he goes into
the real wild world and he realized i'm
actually very regular regular i'm
nothing special
okay
but what class of women are you talking
about like how intellectual are they
where do they come from what
women or you think all women think like
this most women yeah
would you think they think they're about
i think they should yeah because you get
the dating app data which allows women
to be very honest and women only swipe
right five percent of the time
they're not ugly in pictures though no
women find 80 no no women find 80 of men
unattractive not uh okay like
unattractive but what about in person no
just anywhere anywhere yeah 80 of men
they find unattractive but because i've
spoken to them or because on face value
they like there's something chemically
that they're like because they've had
better sexually and they're just their
standards are skewed
yeah so a lot of a lot of times i'll
hear girls say things like oh he's
medium ugly and i'm like no sis that's
your level
but but you know that term you've heard
it right
oh you've never heard me you're not on
social media right yeah i'm snapchat
yeah so one out of one out of three men
either are virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year
and that's the trend so that's the trend
that's going going on the last like 50
years where it's like 50 years yes
slowly it's a bigger and bigger
percentage of men aren't having sex so
but if most women are having sex that
means they're having sex with the same
guys
that's like why do you think women say
things like men are trash all men cheat
dead
because we're all sleeping
because everything funny has a little
bit of truth in it right but it's
because we're dating the same ones okay
um
so for the past 50 years
only 20 of men have been having sex is
that right look at that right roughly
yeah yeah
so prior to that
more men were having sex because women
were less free
in a way yeah because because we had
more we had we had to vet men more
because we could possibly get pregnant
because birth control is a fail-safe
right if you get if you get an iud you
have like a 99 chance of not getting
pregnant okay so that's a fail-safe and
if that doesn't work you can get an
abortion
now oh i'm sorry there's a there's a
sorry it's hard
but and so they we had to prioritize a
man that was going to stick around okay
and typically like we got married
younger and the men around us vetted the
men around us like our fathers would vet
guys before we would go on dates with
them and stuff and like women we're kind
of dumb like a guy can sweet talk us and
like
yeah
like we're not
you know what it's like
because you know it's true right
and so but men vet men better because
they can tell you when someone's like
talking [ __ ] to you
because if a guy's smooth he had to
practice to get there boy guys aren't
just born smooth
i mean sometimes
they don't want to hear it like i have
female friends that'll ask me stuff
um about the way guys are acting and you
tell them and they
they're still okay with what's happening
because they'll still like
go along with
the game that he's playing because
deep you probably know it's a game but
you're enjoying it
and you want you want him
i think i think they just see um
i think they just see potential
they go
the game's happening
hopefully he's gonna change
um i want him to change and
he'll change for me because
he's with me he's here and
this is what i want so
it's the delusion in them selfish in
some regards but it is what it is
women their attraction is is
they take their ideas from other women
they want the guy that they're
they're going after to be validated by
other women and that's what part yes and
she realizes he's the alpha within this
group
and where it changes revolutionary
previously it might have been
um
say being able to be a fighter being
able to protect now it's it's about
wealth high value status within your
echo chambers or the values you respect
you need other women
and importantly women that you respect
for example the the commodity in the
sexual marketplace as women is her looks
other women that you recognize as pretty
to also have a vested interest in this
guy
and that's
how random win the game
why do you think um
why are women grossed out at dirty jokes
but the same women do those things in
the bedroom
because they don't
because they don't want to seem like
they do that they don't it's like the
stigma that they have oh i don't want to
seem like a like a [ __ ] but in the dark
they like [ __ ] me out let's let's let me
like
it's just
it's just that like image that they want
to keep and so
it's it's crazy it's like if you do it
just own up to it and just
if they did that a lot of men value
purity
yeah i think that men would be
attractive if she was to say like yeah i
like the khaki on my face i think it's
the same reason
like body count so yeah are you talking
about like with uh with friends or like
if a dude said that dirty joke to them
they were like oh no i don't do that
yeah i don't know it's just a question
okay
yeah i think what friends they
they don't seem with friends they
trust both with men's and friends they
hide it
and they don't like tell it i think with
men they do it more
it gets to a point with friends like
maybe a friend will say
and i've had this in my friend group
they'll say something like they did to
with their dude and they'll be like oh
she's she's crazy too she's a freak in
the bedroom too i can say what i what i
did as well and then there'll be like a
conversation of what they did and it's
like an openness once they find out that
one girl is just as crazy yeah they'll
be like okay i can find comfort in this
group now but with dudes i don't
i don't think i can open up
yeah
so i have a question for the guys
so you you said that body count doesn't
matter so much to you
no no in the context of what we're
asking yeah so so question how many
bodies is too many bodies how many
bodies is too many bodies
damn i have to give a hardline
responsibility you could say plus or
minus like you know roughly
i think
the age i'm at now
mid to late 20s
i think anything in the in london
because everyone will lie about the body
count i know where the people are on in
school
below 10 is good
10 to 15
is okay
and then below 20 is like
you wouldn't agree with it but you'd
accept it because i've come to realize
having done numbers myself
[Music]
so many people lie that is is
yeah and especially i've got one thing
i've come to the realization as well
is that cool say at one point i was
chopping out and going through but the
reality is
is these same women were probably
getting chopped out by guys like me who
were just time wasters
so probably from what i'm attracted to
is like echo chambers like i could go to
for that nerdy girl who plays chess and
her body counts probably below three but
then like if i tried to put my phone in
a bum she might be like whoa what's
going on so what's that
that'd be telling them
or she might not she might be on she
might she might be on it she might be
like she might be on it you know
just ease her into it
[Laughter]
what about what about you um i'd say
below 10. below 10. yeah
um
it's a wife yeah yeah oh it's a wife
yeah um
yeah i'm going to say below 10. below
10.
but no questions
i find with a lot of men
a lot of men think they're the guy in it
i'm not saying you might not the guy but
a lot of men will say mad numbers like
r5 because i've slept with ten and part
of it is the insecurity of like wait if
she's on the same numbers at me it's the
realization that maybe they're not the
guy
so do you think that plays into it as
well because i know a bag of man i slept
with like say less than 10 and they're
like no i have to be like three but
that's like a [ __ ] in their masculinity
what do you mean think on that
wait could you just reframe that in like
a simpler context like because i that
was so long-winded but i kind of get
what you're talking about what i'm
trying to say is like do you think that
that is based on that figure alone or is
it any way related to yours
oh okay
yeah all right i think it's related but
it's more like
that i'm assuming you okay would i be
correcting saying you wouldn't be with
someone that slept with more
people than you yeah am i correct in
saying that correct so do you think say
i don't know what your figures say if it
was say a hundred yeah do you think that
figure would be higher
yes
yeah yeah that's what i find with a lot
of men is like a lot of men they
wouldn't go for someone who's near them
because a lot of men they think they're
the guy
and the fact that a woman an attractive
woman has slept with near the same
amount of bodies as you
maybe are not as special as you think
um my my kind of dictation on numbers is
based on like math i'm thinking
all right under 10 or under single
digits with she's probably got
some way to kind of pair bond with me
at a point where it's not a case where
her whole hair bonding process is gone
she she's less likely to be alpha
widowed
and like i don't and i don't know at
what level
she's been alpha with like i might say
oh i've alpha widowed a girl yeah but
then the guy that alford her is on and
next thing but one thing i'll say in
this london year
the only way to really find that is to
find girls of a long-term relationship
if that's what you value yeah because
say we're you're around mid-20s say you
really
lose your virginity at say 16 which is
the average in this country that most
girls lose it at yeah if you do one a
year for
up to the age of now that's
10.
but the reality is we know what girls
get onto when they find their sexuality
in terms of in uni et cetera and i just
know so many girls because i had a lot
of female friends
so many women just lie
and they just play the game so it's like
we'll say this is too much but the
reality is you don't even really know i
mean ignorance is bliss if you're not
but i think you also want someone with
like similar morals to you i guess
especially if
if that's what they were doing at uni
you can't just
wipe out the aspect of your personality
they might be more likely to cheat later
on if yeah no i agree i would agree if
you're more promiscuous you're probably
more likely to be well i think that's
why guys stay younger
yeah they do but less baggage less yeah
less bodies less stress and like it's
it's it's it's a it's a newer model in
it
one thing the eye
i said this one
um one thing that i kind of do when
dating a girl i literally look at her
friends
i'll be like birds are the same feathers
plot together oh 100 so more time if a
girl's like hiding
her promiscuity i will literally look at
her friends how are her friends moving
and like usually she's got
two or three her friends
and i'm like oh so this is what you guys
are on
and now you're showing me a version that
doesn't look anything like your friends
yeah 100 i i won't even test the waters
because i'll know that
she'll she'll pull a fast one on me
would you say though
because i see what you're saying but i
just think men have a lot to lose
nowadays
when it comes to like paternity flaw
fraud you know um
paternity fraud they said cuck-holdery
and divorce grape as a grim reality for
men
like wait where's this cockholding
that's that's quite mad so is russell
wilson like
sort of when you think about it like
because he he's a [ __ ]
you know but you know it's like and
don't get me wrong like he's very
respectable and like all he's
accomplished he's like a one percent
dude but it's it's sad when you see a
one percent dude wife a hoe
it's just like you could
it's not like you didn't have options as
well why is she at ho
because she i mean she dated like every
rapper before she don't respect him as
well yeah and and if you watch could you
pull up the ish could you pull up a
video of the video of her on top of the
car because i think that that would be a
good one to show i thought she said the
goodies stayed in the jar
yeah but that's what that's that's why
that's what every slag says though
whenever you met a slag that says i'm a
slag and i love [ __ ] never
the real ones
wait um sierra
i'm gonna pull it out but basically like
the the the idea is like can you turn a
home into a housewife
and and the thing is like your habits
are who you are so if a girl's been
doing something for 10 years
like is she gonna magically stop one day
probably not
it's the same thing with a guy if he's
cheated in every single relationship
he's been and he's probably gonna cheat
on you too
i disagree and see people can change i
think the landing can change the man can
grow man yeah
but i think the
the
actions of
um either being a hoe like what comes
with it it may manifest in different
areas she may not go out and do the
things but it may
may how do i explain it
it can
it can be in different areas of her life
so if even in guys in with cheating if
they don't if they say okay i'm not
going to cheat on my wife if they don't
fix it if they don't work on it and
change it it can
manifest in different ways it may not be
in cheating but it may not it may be in
different areas and work in other
relationships they may be just dodgy in
however they approach different things
it shall send it to you in the dms i got
you um i just found it uh no because the
the thing is like so i asked my dad i
was like dad do people change
and he said to me this is my dad's
wisest person i know i swear to god he
knows everything about everything and he
goes
yes
they get worse over time
and he said so anything that you see
like at a young person like i swear it
is going to get worse it does not get
better
and because you can't change like okay i
used to drink i don't i don't drink
anymore but there's always going to be a
part of me that wants to drink and
that's never going to go away
and so any guy that dates me
like he he knows there might be a chance
that i'm going to want to drink again
because that is what i used to do
it's just like yeah watching this uh
netflix series um it's called the i'm a
killer and so
this guy killed somebody he may say like
oh
i
um changed my life gave my life to
christ but that that instinct it may be
suppressed it may be in the back of his
mind but it's still there you can't
forget who who you were and what you've
done is still going to be there and it
is going to affect you in some type of
way not saying that you're going to do
it again but they're still there
but you'll probably do it what i would
say no what i was saying earlier is i
100 agree with what you're saying if
you're promiscuous in your past you're
more likely to be promiscuous in the
future my problem is like
with promiscuity as you said women are
great pretenders and they fool mr beta
male
how does these men who often say ah i
want a woman who's got less bodies than
ten how do they even find this is my
point
are you saying like oh
i'm saying most women
are bigger hoes than you think yeah
because why
why
why should a woman not be sexual i don't
understand like the reason is
if you if you have the desire to get
married and to be with that one person
you're essentially making it harder on
yourself to
physically be like okay i'm gonna be
with this person forget about all these
other dudes because there's things like
alpha within where you have this dude
that just
rocked your world just change your life
and you can never get him out of your
brain because of all the partners you've
been with and then you have just areas
where if you slept with all these dudes
your ability to is a parabon parabon
with your husband is going to be hard
because you've just freely given
yourself to all these other dudes to
where when it comes to your husband it's
going to be like
yeah i love him but he doesn't do this
this this like this person did that
person that that person did so it's like
you have all these bits and pieces of
these other dudes that just do men not
have the same thing not in the same way
women do because it's like weird men can
love multiple women at the same time
so it's kind of like if if a guy has an
ex-girlfriend it's weird i talked to i
talked to this pickup artist like um i
went to a pickup artist boot camp this
dude
so good with women like literally slept
with like three girls in three days like
whatever and he told me he's like yeah
the girls after me they always get seem
to get married after like i sleep with
them and he's like i still get mad i'm
like do you want them i'm like he's like
no
i'm good i just and it's because men
release a hormone that makes them like
territorial so men can love multiple
women on the same time because that's
natural to them there was 17 women
reproducing for every one guy where
women can only love one man because
and it has to be the best that she can
do because typically you you were with
the strongest guy otherwise another guy
would kill him and take you with and
kill your kids yeah so i think even like
the way we're designed reproductively
like we can impregnate multiple women
easily but you get pregnant once and
you're like out of the game for like a
while
if that makes sense and then also it's
like um the whole lock and key
analogy where a cheap lock can be opened
by any key
however a master lock can only be opened
by one key so it's the idea that
whatever's behind the lock is precious
and needs to be
withheld at all costs and if it's given
out freely then it loses value and the
key that can open many locks is also
more valuable yeah
yeah because men i don't think most
girls think that like men are sleeping
around all the time but guys have to
work yeah they have to work really hard
to be able to get girls they have to
figure out money they have to go to the
gym where we're just 15 14 and guys
start hitting on us that's true and and
so it's
it's not impressive to sleep with a lot
of guys and it actually repulses them
because historically they had to ensure
paternity so they had to say i want to
make sure that kid is mine and i'm not
passing on my resources to some some a
kid that's not mine so that's why
they're biologically predispositioned to
like pure women
for relationships they'll they'll screw
anything but some of the obsessions with
teens
like was the appeal i would i wouldn't
say what do you mean obsession with
teens because most most guys i know like
like young women how how young as young
as as is legal that's legal yes yes it's
a bit mud still um i don't know if
they're obsessed with them i think
they're obsessed with the idea of the
purity in them like if they were
if they were 20 and still like that oh
they would go for that but it's just the
idea of like they're still
pure they still they don't
i can conquer it there can be no other
father it will only be mine yeah yeah
pretty much
yeah and and so men value youth
fertility
and beauty
and so the younger you are the more you
have of that right okay because you know
men aren't lining up to date 50 year
olds so at some point it goes away
unfortunate
the the modern woman demonizes anything
that is uh that detriment to her so for
example as us as men when we're young we
realize that
all right when you're like 16 you
realize the local drug dealer who's like
19 will pull up in the vauxhall coursa
will take the sexiest girl of the year
and you just have to take it because
you're young and that's it and that's
just the game is the game
you see women when they hit
like say touching 30 they'll go out to
clubs and they'll say
why is everyone in here a kid or they'll
start demonizing men of their age who
are dating 23 year olds like oh why
can't you get a woman your age and they
don't accept that power dividers now
because okay once you see this you can't
really unsee it every time men have a
standard women shame them for it body
count yeah so every time so the things
that men value they're shamed for
valuing
so so for example if a guy says i want a
young girl i want her to be in shape i
want no kids
they're they're saying you're fat phobic
you're slut-shaming
but girls can go on a public platform
and say i deserve this this this and
this and nobody bouts and i
i like i deserve a guy that treats me
right i deserve a guy that makes this
amount of money i deserve a guy that's
this tall and no one will say anything
okay where do you think that comes from
i just think society is geared towards
women we make 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions so i just think
everything in the media is for women
except this channel like the video
i think i think part of it is
women have sold this narrative from such
a young age that you can be whatever you
want and it doesn't matter so like for
example
body positivity um
body count doesn't matter whereas for
men
if you're
short bold in fat and you're broke
there's no support group for broke men
there's no support group for fat men
other than weight watchers in cell yeah
could it also be like but even even
insult right that's that's like a term
to to shame men or like make fun of them
it's like derogatory but if if a girl's
fat there's a whole movement to put her
on the cover of a magazine nobody's
trying yeah no one's trying to put the
the short broke men on the cover of
magazines yeah cause they're trying to
kill people what say it again
i'm trying to kick can i say that one
yeah it's not trying to kill people
they're trying to kill people maybe in
so it's generally associated with that
i'll move on
but yeah i think for women like the the
feminism movement came from because of
feminazi movement yeah
like
i'm not the feminazi movement
but
the the
feminism movement came from women that
were repressed and unhappy and had been
sold this
belief that they were only due this in
life
this is all you need to
find a suitable husband get married have
children and that is your lot and be
happy with it so did you know that
feminism was actually started by men
no
it started in um seneca falls in new
york and it had um
200 men 100 women there okay
and to me feminism is and always has
been freedom without responsibility
starting with the right to
vote because most women didn't actually
want the right to vote because it came
with getting drafted if today in 2022
there was a war
and you had to pick do i want to vote
in society but if i vote i go and fight
to war or
you can or you cannot vote
and not have to go to war i've often
wanted to go to war you want to be
fighting in the front lines my dad was
in the sas okay
[Music]
so front lines
guys yeah yeah you don't know like how
do you know i like fighting
i personally i'm i'm in the kitchen i'm
not i'm not brave i'm not
maybe
something yeah but i'm saying like the
most women didn't want the freedom
because it came with responsibility so
feminism came in and said screw it
anyone can vote even if you don't have
the responsibility that comes with it
and so every time it's even with um with
birth control right you get the freedom
to sleep around going against biology
without the responsibility of the kid
because you can put the data on child
support that's a fail safe
okay and then on top of that you can
also get money from the government
that's a fail-safe yeah
so
and so women are incentivized to get
kids off of rich guys
i'm not saying i'll do some get them off
of broke eyes i don't
but
but but it you see so we keep putting
these laws in that take away the
responsibility from women and give us
more freedom but i don't think it's
making us happy because
the the
most unhappy demographic graphic is
women that are single childless and over
the age of 45 life gets pretty lonely
yeah after a certain age or not you're
gonna look weird in the clubs
you're gonna look weird going out and
like but is it not a natural progression
of society for us to
seek different relationships rather than
just let's be married and have kids well
if we keep seeking different
relationships and not having kids then
the older generation is going to die off
and there's not going to be a new
generation to fill the needs that we
need to keep the society i'm not sorry
i'm inviting children is that positive
to like oh mumzy got jilled by me down
the road no i didn't mean like multiple
different relationships i meant
relationships that were happy and rather
than something that is expected of you
because we
are in a war and and you need to have a
man at home and a woman i mean sorry a
man out and a woman at home like
different relationships in terms of one
that you're happy in do you that's what
people expect now right to be happy
rather than just to put up with a man
that is
your husband for
do you think relationships are about
happiness
is it like them to be
do you think in 50 years if you want to
be married to someone like let's say you
got married tomorrow you live to be 80
50 your marriage
um but is it realistic to expect you're
going to be happy all 50 years
no but
now it's not expected that you stay in
an unhappy relationship generations
before yes because there are many
reasons not just because well i think
generations before would laugh at us to
be honest i think the wives from the
1950s would laugh at us when we leave
because we're not happy because you know
she's like i had a whole side chick
across town he had a whole second family
and you guys are leaving because you're
not happy
do you all come from happy homes with
parents that stay together
i mean not um
yeah i mean my i did i have two parents
they have 10 kids
and um i mean they weren't always happy
though
and so what i would see is like growing
up my friends parents would be unhappy
and they decided to get divorced and it
didn't it wasn't really great for the
kids where my parents there were times
when they were unhappy and they just
figured it out
and just you know because because to
them it was always about us it wasn't
about their happiness it was about us i
can attest to that um
my
my grandmother
um
her my grandfather had a family across
town she stayed with him i always asked
like well why didn't you leave and she's
like i just stayed with them i had kids
with them that was my husband and he had
the other family and it wasn't like she
didn't know about them or anything she
just stayed and that's something that's
very taboo nowadays to stay with someone
that has a family across town i think
it's just
easier for us to be like i don't like it
i don't want it i'm gonna choose
something else i think we've become
quite individualistic as a culture so we
don't
maybe think about the community or the
bigger picture or like like raising the
next generation so you you put yourself
first and your own like
happiness first yes so i think that they
were
more realistic
in terms of what they could achieve in
the sense of
in those times if you had three kids by
a man you know that the grass isn't
green on the other side
that you might have been a brand new
mercedes but having three kids is like
being a cat d written off vehicle like
our new manager
how many men are really going to take
you on in in in that case and that's
just being the
reality of it and that's me like i hate
to bring anecdotes in it that's me
growing up around
loads of dysfunctional relationships
like
dude he really wants to take you on like
that you just your caliber of man that's
gonna date you is not what and it was
like when when you were 23 yeah and also
they didn't
i don't know when child support started
or when all of the government handouts
started but
if like back in the day that wasn't
really a thing it's like you stay with
the man because he's a provider of the
family if i leave that means i have to
take care of the x amount of kids that i
have at home i have to get a job take
care of them have to find out who's
going to babysit them take them to
wherever it's like i'd rather stay with
the man that's providing for the family
and deal with whatever stuff that he has
going on because
it's gonna be harder on me to leave than
to stay but nowadays it's easy for women
to be like okay peace out i time to
prune up or i get half the stuff that he
has or i get money for him from child
support so i was like okay either way
it's easy for me to leave than to stay
because there is consequences and when
you take away the consequences of in
society like people
people damn near do whatever they want
you know because before you you might be
homeless if you if you left your husband
i know but it just like everything
you're saying is like you have to put up
with what he's doing or else you're
gonna be worse off now it's like well if
he's being a [ __ ] you can still leave
well but that's that's through the
mindset maybe like men you've dealt with
in the past haven't like haven't been
great i don't because that's i i don't
know you personally but that's that's
what an example like your example my
personal like my family
so um my mom and dad met when they were
17
love at first sight
40 years together
happy families
he left
i was in my 20s all right so he he
decided after a year a bad year of
marriage he met someone else and he
decided to leave
he came from a family that
you said this was your dad yeah my dad
okay so i was in my 20s so it's not like
i had this like childhood where i was
hating men like you know um but he came
from a family
his parents were together very religious
he had
four
brothers and a sister
none of them none of their marriages
worked
either through one of them cheating one
of them leaving they were unhappy i just
i don't think it's enough to say that a
woman needs to be a certain way in order
for a marriage to work
because it's not true
did you ever ask your like dad for his
side of the story oh yeah no yeah like i
was the one that found out about the
affair i confronted him the night before
he left and oh my gosh yeah i would be
so sad it was awful yeah i can't even
imagine but at the same time they had a
bad year and it was horrendous i was
living with them at the time it was
horrendous to be around and i wanted him
to be happy so i was like go be free but
now i think that was a terrible way to
deal with a 40-year marriage or
relationship they were together 40 40
years and he ended it in an email
he went away to afghanistan and sent her
an email to me and my two brothers he
sent an email all he did was change the
name from like each of our names
basically
what he is
this is a woman that moved from country
to country to country she was with him
through the war like
yeah multiple wars
sacrificed her life
like everything she wanted to do for him
and he still left one bad year
like it was horrendous
is that what he said he said it was one
bad year it was 18 months that he so he
was in afghanistan work stopped funds
were withdrawn and he came back to
england he hated living in england he
was unhappy she was unhappy because he
was unhappy they didn't talk they were
at each other's throats they didn't
communicate
he then sought solace in another woman
that he knew in school they reconnected
on facebook
like social media is out here ruining
lives
so
it's
it's not enough to say that and and this
is just an example there are many
examples of women being good we're good
women
and it's still ending so so i don't
disagree with you that like like i think
that's horrible like yeah that
that i'm sorry that happened to you
actually that's that would be that would
traumatize me
but the majority of the time women are
the ones leaving
and the divorce rate increased after
hormonal
hormonal birth control was introduced
so and i the reason i think women leave
more is because we're incentivized to do
so to the point we're paid
so because we can we can leave and take
half have you ever heard the phrase it's
cheaper to keep her
yeah
excuse me
so so we don't have a consequence for
leaving which we had before
because we can take half his money like
most of the richest women on earth
got their money through divorce
because if a man leaves with the kids
the woman doesn't have to pay child
support the woman doesn't have to
contribute anyway she can go out and
live her life yeah and the man because
the man is a provider he still has to
work and do everything but do you all
come from places where
the man is the provider and the woman is
just like this freeloader
no
i think that's good that's quite
divisive to say freeload though because
she's got different roles yeah but she's
got a different role she's got many
roles and i like so i grew up in south
africa so a lot of my parents friends
are south african of course uh and i
know a woman that has done very well
in business and financially insecure but
her husband essentially well say
freeloader for one of her better term
when
their marriage ended
she had to pay him half
it happens yeah but it's it's only men
only win three percent of alimony cases
depending on where you are south africa
is 50 50 split is it really that's
interesting right there you have to
doesn't matter who the money is when you
are married it's 50 50. right so um the
stats that like the the places i'm
talking about is typically the west so i
don't i don't i'm not going to pretend i
know anything about south africa i don't
but like the point is that men typically
face consequences for their actions on
top of that
there are women's shelters
there's not men's shelters not really
not at the same rate there's women's
shelters there's there's women's
empowerment there's not men's
empowerment
and it's it's okay like honestly a
couple months ago or like maybe a year
or two ago now i once said you see it
it's like you can't unsee it
would you say that that is in a way a
function of like the patriarchy
it depends what you mean by the
patriarchy so like let's say like one
function of the patriarchy is to protect
women
in a way so they're
over protecting women and
now that women are able to you know go
into the workforce and earn money for
themselves and be independent and
they're essentially safe and equal to
men
in society there are still those
functions in place but by the
patriarchy that protect them and i guess
even incentivize certain
bad behaviors
um
because when i hear patriarchy i always
think it's oppressing women so it's
interesting you're saying protecting
yeah because when you when people use
that word typically they mean that the
patriarchy is oppressing women yeah i'm
just trying to flip on you're flipping i
mean because i i don't think we live in
a patriarchy if anything i would argue
it's maybe a matriarchy yeah um in my
opinion because women get so many
fail-safes but i think it's innate in
men it's the same way even though i talk
about on this channel all the time equal
rights equal laughs if a girl hits you
you can hit back
you can but but there's a but there's a
part of me that if i saw a dude deck a
girl even after like it's like oh
even even if she deserved it and i just
think that's kind of innate in everybody
yeah
true
okay i'm gonna take a second we're gonna
read super chats and then we'll watch
the video i sent you after that okay
guys um all super chats are going
towards the uh the updated studio we
want to move into a three bedroom and um
actually i'm not going to tell you guys
where i got too excited
[Music]
but basically we want to move so we can
do all different types of videos and
channels like we want to take people
from the shows and do like dating shows
we want to do like a smash or pass type
episode we want to do uh just a bunch of
different way to do mukbangs in here
jess wants to do a little live stream on
her channel
so um but in order to do that it's
really important a fool to marry a 30
year old that has miles of d the broken
woman has the
the broken women have 1d no way my d
could keep her in a divorce she could
obtain everything only after a short
marriage rose i disagree with the
mindset that you choose to be married to
someone expecting it to fail pick a good
man with high values not someone who is
attractive sentience
blonde's response to happiness question
shows how our societies are degrading
and continue to plummet in a cesspool
long lost are the notions of duty honor
and selflessness while focusing on
wanton hedonism florent and
um
blonde lady would be scared of a spider
um
almighty high long um blondie said bravo
six going dark da pool i was taught game
by a pimp in australia he said always
said it's the man's fault patrice
o'neill said the same thing both men
said that men and women love differently
men love women as a possession oh that's
true as a possession there's a position
that's what my brother told me he says
like
you know i'm gonna i'll never mind
i'm not okay um silly sausage it's funny
older girls complain guys are going
after younger girls yet when they are
young they prefer older guys you did the
same thing the older you are you realize
you can't compete with your past self um
zachary payne pearl you could really
benefit from reading the theology of the
body by john pope paul ii um kendrill
scott
how come you don't have it set up where
you can receive bits on twitch just
wondering um it's probably because i
don't understand twitch like at all but
you know if you dm me i'll try to figure
that out
silly sausage that at the what what act
from each of your past have you
personally noticed that has come back to
haunt you most girls don't realize too
many partners lingers over you like a
bad smell to new guys
do you think that's true
if you can discern it that's the problem
you don't it's it's it's very ignorant
is
london i can only speak for my city
london is the gulag it's the trenches
like finding someone that that is is
he's the one out here yeah everyone's
been getting run through by the mandate
which is what is
what do you guys think
i
i think there's some truth to what
you're saying i don't know if you could
tell really
i don't think it's just london no i
think that's true because if i meet
someone from london and i tell them i'm
from canada
no there's no savages in like nah the
savages haven't got there once they get
to the big smoke it's all over
what do you think guys
sorry what was the question
um
do you think that
too many partners lingers over a girl
like a bad smell to guys oh 100
yeah yeah yeah 100 yeah okay the count
25 thank you for the super chat um mon
cars something hey pearly can you re r
can you or real femme sapien debate the
jebediah girl role of tomasi debated she
kept saying she's not one of those girls
oh my gosh i was actually invited to
debate her but i live in london
i live in london so if you all want to
cash out me for a flight if you want to
catch
yeah florida's kind of it's kind of
expensive right now we're about to get a
new studio um 90 free toe pet when a
girl tells you their body count you have
to add five plus you think that's true i
heard you have to add seven that's what
we say over here add seven i heard
multiply by three that's what i heard
multiplied by three
oh yeah that was it that was it from a
guy minus seven for a woman times by
three yeah that was it interesting
sentience since impaired and since
impaired pear bonding paternity fraud
culture and divorce grape is a grim
reality any man who accepts higher than
five bodies from her is asking for all
the above above five are
compuls
couple
i think that's what he meant but he
spelled it wrong sperm rags um
matt butcher
feminism divorce laws and welfare crush
the traditional family men are wising up
and staying clear the odds of a good
outcome are horrible that crypto guy if
a woman can't or won't give up hypergamy
then polygamy is the only answer sharing
is caring um
many women today believe that their
chances of getting married is the same
as their chances of getting laid
look ps look out for some of the super
chats and jada quotes if tesla stock
hits a hundred dollars this week we keep
up the good work oh this is our member
of the week chris
chris chris is in the house fingers
crossed for tesla
stock
sentience most men don't men don't cheat
as bad because only 20 percent of men
ever get sexual access and attention the
bottom 80 percent of men don't even get
the chance to cheat if they do get a
woman they would be thankful
they they would be thankful he got her
to to they would be too thankful they
got her to ever cheat 90 free topi the
more a guy does not care it drives the
girl loco
um garen oh this is um
keifer hunter talk about the audacity
video with rebecca i'm going to refresh
the page really quick also guys at some
point probably not this stream but
we're gonna start doing just like 20 or
over super chats that we're going to
read because sometimes we get too many
and we can't yeah we can't go through
all of them um deaf fool 101 please ask
your guests
okay this is the last one so i'm going
to ask people why what do you think it's
what do you think is true mike tyson
said that your woman loves you for her
survival but your mom loves you for your
survival
yeah i saw this that's what
we'll go around right yeah go around
what do you think of this phrase
mike tyson said that your woman loves
you for her survival but your mom loves
you for your survival
yeah it all comes down to to be an alpha
uh i can't remember what kind of monkey
does this but
i'll
i'll leave the reference to pearl um
there's a monkey that basically he's the
alpha and he has like a group of women
that he [ __ ] and these little baiter
monkeys stand on the top of the hill
and then what they do is they wait for
when um the king monkey the alpha monkey
is with one of his ladies
and then they'll debate a little pusio
will run down
and then kill the baby the baby will
like smash its head on the rock and then
it will still quickly scuttle and hurry
away
the woman
or the female
monkey would then grieve of that child
and then we'll actually go out and then
go and seek
the the the killer of the monkey the
little baby monkey and then look to mate
with him
to show because what what would happen
is that guy or the king alpha has shown
that he cannot protect the offspring so
that's why she's looking for
the protection survival of them
you see it so that sums up what make
tyson was saying
that
[Music]
i mean nature's crew
what do you think
um
yeah of course a mother's loves more
than
a woman that didn't
grow carry and birth you i feel like
that's a given
okay
you know
what do you think yeah i would agree
with that like when a woman becomes a
mother i guess she would definitely
focus her care and her attention to her
kids more so that's why of course a
mother would love you
for your survival not for her survive of
course
i mean she would not expect you to
protect her anything she's the one who's
doing that that's
that's i would say natural instinct
exactly instinct so i would definitely
say that that's true that's definitely
true
yeah um how i'm understanding is
like i guess your mother would love you
unconditionally whereas your wife would
love you conditionally on the condition
that you can protect and like be
the alpha male that she wants you to be
and what not so i would agree with
example yeah yeah
yeah
what do you think chess yeah i would
agree except for the moms that are
that love their
kids i love their sons like
their husbands
there's an exception but
according to that yeah i would agree
but do you think women feel that way
because they feel threatened like a
black i find a lot of women when they
find like a mama's boy
like they they hate it like they feel
threatened i heard the mom feels that
you know the girl the girlfriend feels
friend a lot of women hate on hate on
mama's i don't think
i don't think the girlfriend froze that
i think the mom felt yeah
she's like yeah that's that's my man
that's my son and they take the place of
the father essentially but the way i see
it is a lot of women feel that a lot of
girls will feel threatened because they
know that this woman is going to have
the highest standards and
because he's he rates her opinion so
much that
no matter what
she's always going to have to get a seal
of approval and that can be quite
intimidating are you she knows
he won't [ __ ] her hopefully
she knows he won't like she knows he's
not she's not sexual competition
so i feel like there's some security in
that no no no i think
i'm talking about in terms of approval
that no matter what you feel for this
guy if the mum says
she's not the one so that's going to
happen
i think there's two things it's a guy
that can't make his own decisions yeah
yeah and that's extremely unattractive
as a guy that can't be a man and not do
what his mother says you know because at
some point you have to make your own
decisions
and this and so if if you're talking to
a guy and he says oh i can't do this
because of my mom
yeah
and then the second the second thing is
i think sometimes there's moms that like
compete like they don't have a man so
they almost compete
with like that's the only attention she
gets from men is from her son
and so like she's almost competing with
you yeah and it's a really good son
and she's like raised you into the
husband that she would have wanted yeah
it's like
you know
i think we could all think i can think
of an archetype right now
yes
okay i'm gonna show you guys uh this is
going back to the original topic that
the video um i sent you ish
um sierra
basically this is
we're gonna talk about if we think this
is acceptable behavior from a wife
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone and welcome back to my
channel chiara showed off her moves in a
new twerking video at the gas station
but the fuel prices in the background
were the start of the clip
[Music]
[Music]
joining a group of dancers in the new
jump music video kiara twerked on top of
a ford bronco parked outside of a gas
station it's time to pull up and make
that thang jump chiara
are we back in okay so
so
um
this is an example of why guys say you
can't take a hoe into a housewife
because basically what she did was she
said she changed
got the kids that she wanted from
russell
and then when she got what she wanted
she's doing this [ __ ] again
do you guys think that's acceptable
behavior from a wife
i mean
she's a she's a dancer okay but
it depends on how much she said she's
changed because i don't know how much
she said she
she waited till she was married with
russell oh [ __ ] well before she started
working was she a mother no no to have
sex what yeah it hurt you didn't know
that well
oh okay i'm sorry i left a piece of this
story absolutely yeah so so basically
after she dated the bad boy she said she
changed she was a new person
and she decided yeah found god and women
tend to find god around like 27 to like
30s early 30s because because it's in
like times running out so they need to
base it's a mating strategy so they need
to basically say i'm more pure than i
actually am
and like i'm a higher value woman than i
actually am basically but she was a
virgin no
no
no
no no no no no that's the point so she
she slept with all the rappers and then
made the next guy yeah okay
she says she would change didn't have
sex with anybody and then
once she got rustled then that's when
she
went back in yeah so they dated for a
year didn't have sex they got married
and so she this is he's thinking this is
a godly one it's the same thing with
megan good
i don't know okay oh american actress
yeah um but
but basically
now
she got they get they got the kids
they're a little bit older
and now this behavior is coming back 10
years later basically
so she was already having the kids at
that time of the video
no this is now so she has three kids now
yes
dated now basically yes
and the the and the argument is you
can't marry a hoe because she will
always return to the streets
i hear that um in terms of like the
twerking
i think i'm giving her a lot of leeway
because she's a dancer but if she
actually was like became born again and
she was just
full-on christian wasn't doing anything
like that then yeah but in terms of her
career
you don't think you can she's a
performer yeah you can't you can't
perform without twerking
on a car
yeah i mean
we all see the same video yeah it's
what i'm saying is it's part of a brand
so i think it's similar to how you were
saying that um
um
the wherever that young guy's name is
and how he was trapped by brittany
renner yeah um so it's like ej
washington yeah so like i don't know
about i think yeah i think part of kim
k's brand is giving glogglog so what
should she return to gibbon blog because
that's how she got famous oh
it's not great that's a great analogy
it's it's it's it's an analogy
it's a great one
yeah i don't i don't i don't think
that's their comment i don't think i
don't think it's appropriate i don't
think it's appropriate behavior
i don't think it's appropriate behavior
but
i don't i'm kind of excusing it i
wouldn't um
she's autistic
but she like she has yeah i'm not
disregarding that she's a dancer i
i grew up listening to sierra group
seeing her love her music videos but
there's a way like you are portraying
yourself in this way you're portraying
yourself at this as this
wife the essential wife with the family
and everything and then
what there's there's no context of
choreography there's no context of a
song being released there's no context
of that to be able to do that it's just
hey i got these dancers we're going to
go twerk on a car at a gas station i
think so it's not a song
i think it's because i never saw her as
whatever she rebranded herself as
i think that
yeah i think that might be why no
because
that's the thing she's claiming to be
brand new she's just like
no sex before marriage i'm a christian
now
then now you're doing madness yeah
that's yeah i guess she was doing that
if she posted a video and she was
twerking on russell i'd be like oh hey
girl that's your man like go ahead do
that but now it's out of the context of
but when it's just her it's not okay
it it sends like a mixed signal because
if it's just
imagine if it if you
and your girls got a car went to the
petrol station it was like we're going
to twerk real quick and then your
daughter
friends sitting around squirrel
scrolling and sawing yeah and they're
like is this your mom it's like yeah
it's my mom why is she twerking at a
petrol station on a car it's just
it's
difficult because now she's in a setting
to where that not only affects it's not
her anymore it's not her image it
affects her kids and affects russell's
image now that she is doing that and
exposing herself
right yes and do you think that she
wouldn't have discussed it with him
before do you think she just knows maybe
she doesn't feel like she did this and
he had no maybe she doesn't feel like
i i think russell's a samp
and i think i think a lot of guys have
been so conditioned
that they don't even know what they want
do you think it should be a man a woman
expresses her sexuality only in relation
to her man and if it's
i i think her on her own even though he
is as you said a one percent man
it is not okay unless he's there
i i what do you mean by expressing her
sexuality perhaps she likes twerking
perhaps it makes her feel good perhaps
it's something that when she sees
herself she's like
she can
i think i think i think it's provocative
it's something that's gonna
generate her more income it's gonna get
people talking about
so so if i have kids and i want to start
an only fans because it generates more
income do you think that's a good
representation of my kids and my husband
i was on a henry recently um
no no it's not that bad um and uh one of
the girls i just met her on the head too
i've never met her before she was
actually a virgin when she got married
uh and uh she said her boss
she had i think it's a bell i don't know
do you have any friends anyone
uh so yeah we're on a bachelorette and
she said she heard her boss
a bell went off on his phone she was
like i've heard that sound before
where's that from
she'd heard it on tik tok it's from only
fans turns out him and his wife have a
bdsm only fans they're married with kids
do you think that's an optimal
environment for kids to grow up in with
um basically anyone can pay ten dollars
and see their parents having sex because
if you come if you if you went to my
school your mum's breast is going around
all demanding facts
that's you know your mom's best maybe
not optimal but reality now so what do
you think
what do you what effect do you think
that will have do you think it's just
going to become the norm do you think
i hope i think i hope not all my mates
bashing over my mom's breasts like no no
what if they did it anyway without a
picture what would that be they just saw
your moments but that's not the same
okay it's there for advertisement
because at the end of the day it's it's
selfish because you're putting you above
your kid you're putting like wanting
quick cash because that's another way
women are bailed out right if a man
doesn't have a job he's just homeless
if a woman doesn't want to work she can
go on only fans and make six figures
yeah and so it's
it's
you can't really feel bad for those
girls either and say oh you're forced to
be sexualized because
yeah no it's good good
be good but a lot of a lot of those
girls will say that and then come in
after mia khalifa
right
and then come back and and what's the
other girl the
jake paul's
friend's girlfriend
lana rhodes lana rhodes came back and
then says oh i regret it later but it's
like but you got all the benefits and so
they just want quick cash and they're
willing to put their kids and their
family's reputation in the name of it
and yeah i don't think that's ideal for
kids
i'm not saying women can't be sexual at
all but i just think in a relationship
it's going to be better if you do it in
the context with your husband like she
could have she could have went to since
she is a dancer she could have went to a
dance class choreography and there would
have been twerking in the choreography
personally i would think that's okay
because it's within the context of a
choreographed dance it's not just
beyonce random it's not just out at the
gas station just looked like you just
pulled some girls and was like hey i'm
sierra come twerk real quick so is that
literally the video she's just working
on the car there's no like this is a
build up to an album drop it's just
nothing
nothing i think maybe it's a build up to
an album but it's made to look like it's
not giving a lot of benefits
amazing
but one day that's the yeah
for an album drop no beyonce just like
so why do you think she did it what do
you think
because women
women need attention
i think she i think she misses being in
the spotlight i think she misses being
the center of attention because she's
really attractive and so in her 20s like
she was she yeah she was the it girl and
so i think you know in her mid-30s it's
like time's running out and so that's
why i always see these girls doing these
like nude photo shoots like hillary
didn't hillary duff just do one too
it's like right at that party's about to
end and they're like real quick let me
show the world my body
let me
and
i could see i'm not saying she did it
because of that i could see sierra
doing it to be like yeah i still got it
that girl that was in the ride music
video yeah that's the same girl that's
doing it right now i still got the body
after three kids i still got it just
insecure you're saying
possibly
so why do you have to be insecure
like when you're doing these things why
does it have to be insecurity i honestly
don't think it's insecurity like because
i think often times that's a cop-out
women use and say oh i'm just insecure
and like that that's why i'm doing it no
offense but like
but
i like to me i just think she wants
attention i think like girls like that
are used to having a ton of attention
like
how long has sierra been beautiful she
doesn't know what it's like to not be
beautiful yeah because she still is it's
for now it's not like a long time yet no
not really i mean guys at some point at
some i don't know we're not really
checking for sierra though
yeah we're not yeah is there like there
was a time where halle berry was the
most beautiful woman in the world okay
not saying that she's ugly now but you
don't hear people she was she was
relevant then she's not relevant though
yeah difference yeah still beautiful not
relevant it's just at some point like
men aren't lining up to date 50 year
olds
so at some point the party ends it's
some some women are just hot enough they
make it to 40 and they're still hot yeah
but that's the exception it's not the
rule and sierra knows her party is
ending soon and life is going to be very
different because she doesn't know what
it's like to not be beautiful so she
wants to maintain it basically yeah i
just i think she's getting all the
attention she can because time's running
that's my my take is that she's getting
all the time she can because like
honestly girls that are born like nines
and tens part of me feels bad for them
because they don't they don't know what
it's like to not have that attention and
their whole life that's been who they
are
is stunning like they come into a room
they're used to everybody staring at
them and so when it runs out they don't
they don't have anything left
she's 36. that's why people idolize um
the girl that used to be ugly that
glowed up because she she knew what it
was like when she was ugly for the door
to hit you in the face because men
weren't holding the door open struggle
her personality is good they actually
come and shine through
[Music]
applaud for the throw the glow up
what did you say i said applause for the
glow up girls
that's the thing they're always the
funniest too
you're in a shot have you been cute you
always like
you were never ugly come on come on i
had my
face were you ever fat
no i've always been athletic built
but the face is the body can be one way
but the face could be another
mental like 50 percent of women
so i'm gonna wear a bag on my face
why do you think guys would have do like
sex dolls
yeah
they don't really
why do you think they say butterface i
don't care
like it's dark anyways we ain't got to
see your face man that is true this is
crazy they swept 50 of the time on
dating apps
oh my
yeah i believe that like some of my
friends they have tinder plus and
they're just like
tender
man
okay i'm gonna read super chat um i saw
one from zantians i saw him roast me
oh no i know hold on okay um xacien 12.
i'm quite sure twerk sure twerking is
just a stripper move and a common one at
that so i'm wondering if strippers are
becoming more public than private
oh that's true
yeah
um 90 free top blue dress um forgive
your mom and return to your dad
cause if you know what we're going
through
thanks you don't know he leaves this
comment a lot actually it's not just
this
i've like seen this comment copy paste
like you said that to me before
i'm like i'm good
you're missing the point like you're
missing a marriage when you are in a
marriage you respect your husband and
your family's name and your excuses of
its reality it's another reason why men
should avoid women with mindsets like
yours
frazier mcfly
if pearl hasn't had it only fans i would
subscribe
oh my gosh
i've always wanted to only fans where
i'm eating sandwiches
why specifically sandwich i just think
it'd be funny
get the membership yeah like they think
she doesn't need to
um i'm 25. all right you gotta go 15
years and
head to only fans oh god they're not um
um lawrence bullock i'm loving your
channel and your legs bow chicka bow wow
um david red um jess is looking fine
what's her body count 500 super chat
she'll tell you
it's pronounced cop you latouri sperm
rag someone get pearl a dictionary
poppy's a tory
yeah i did not know that i'm sorry
zanteus i don't know a lot of words i
don't know what we're doing i don't know
like i don't know a lot of words um
trevor lane um the girl with the glasses
is back she's so bad
um yes ma'am
you wanna you wanna put your ig in the
chat you wanna put your ig it's gonna be
put and
at the end of the day oh yeah it's it's
it's time to make them search for it
yeah it's on my it's on my story tell my
story
um so
what
percent
of girls do you think have dated a bad
boy
90.
all of them know
not all of them did you know what
one thing i've heard about
a lot of things you've said right daily
is that our most girls are run through
but i've learned in this life right it's
the circles we revolve around in 100
and it was only when like i was working
at university and i was in different
fields speaking to different types of
people that
they are living completely different
lives to what i'm living
so the people around them
don't know
and you can tell they're virgins because
the conversations that they have they're
so innocent they don't they don't know
things and you're just like
oh my gosh there's
many people like you
but i would never have access to that
because i'm not in their circles in
order to do that you'll have to like
[ __ ] infiltrate a world at warcraft
like group and just like sabotage
would you guys pick a girl that had a
lower body count but less chemistry or a
higher body count and more chemistry
what do you mean for life yeah how high
is high though because
let's say plus or minus 10. one girl
slept with 10 less one girl slept with
10 more
well if one was on two then i'll be
right then i wouldn't mind so i'll take
that
okay let's let's say 12. then let's say
12. one's at 12 one's at 22. why is it
22. oh that's a hot one so one's at 12.
what's that 22. yeah
i know i'm picking
who are you thinking oh um well
if my if my like you knew why are you
excited
uh if my average is ten and if i'm
saying like tens of the max or like i
said a long time and she said 12 and
we're talking 12 or 22 i'm picking 22.
well less than chemistry yeah no more
chemistry if it's 22 right yeah yeah
yeah
the pair of endings yeah 12.
yeah i'm picking 22.
what do you think
for life you know
yeah i can't get lost in the arbitrary
figure i just have to pick 22 man like
to be with a dead personality for how
many times yeah but to know you're not
pleasing her in the bedroom
yeah there's a lot of dudes all right
number one
you put me in a room with them i'm
coming out alive all right
so what about when they're going
whatever what about when you see them on
the street and they're you know doing
that impossible i protect the bag
i'm not leaving the house what would you
what would you do if you oh actually
question what would you do if you were
on the street you saw your girl like she
said hi to him and didn't pretend he
didn't existed with that right then it's
done there's many other 22s out there
i thought you were the one
the one yeah i'm saying we're bringing
in the what if scenarios are yeah
so then she's gone if she if she still
talks about it but if you say you're the
one and she's been alpha widowed and she
approaches the dude that alpha widowed
her no but now you're bringing the
analogy of her getting off with it it
never happened to me but i'm saying if
we if for this purpose of the scenario
it did then yeah it's done in it yeah
because it means there's still an
opening so an alpha widow okay
i don't have the definition pulled up
but an alpha widow basically is like
if a girl is a five or a six right most
people are average so most girls five
let's say five she sleeps with a guy
that's an eight
she falls in love with this man that's
why you always hear like girls in
situation chips like they seem to be
more common than relationships these
days
and the reason is it's because a small
percentage of men are sleeping with all
the girls
and so the girl is so in love with that
guy that no other guy can compare
so it doesn't matter who she dates after
they can't beat that guy that's why rola
tomasi says and you're kind of right
with what you were saying it's not about
the number it's about the number of
alphas so if like our girls only slept
with five dudes but one of them is
michael b jordan like it's cooked she's
done
she's done
she's done four and like same with same
with sierra like maybe you know maybe
she only slept with five but they're all
rappers
future like what are you gonna beat
future
and so it's basically like uh some guys
say it's
some some people say it's or the girl
views that as the best she could do like
she can never do better and so then when
she starts aging out of the dating
market when the attention's starting to
go she looks around and grabs the first
guy she can that's willing to marry her
and then she looks at him as less and
doesn't respect him
because she thinks oh i could have done
better i should be with that guy
okay have you seen that dynamic
no
never
no okay sorry
you've never had a girl that's like
afraid like that can't get over her ex
oh no yeah absolutely so in a way that
that that's an alpha widow oh an alpha
widow like the girl that that is always
talking about that one guy act she hates
yeah
so it's such a complex thing to boil
down to he's an alpha
i mean okay the alpha the alpha term i
don't love and it's funny before i was
in this space i i sort of hated that
term too
because it's just like it it
who's alpha right but it doesn't matter
it's the most alpha guy that she can get
so it's the best that she can do it may
not be that he's the guy that walks in
terms of strength intellect financial
like many different things men bring
different things to the table and you
could i could date a really really
strong
man that's in a gang and i know you
protect me or i could date a man that's
really really really rich
or i could date a man that has very high
intellect
like
so so it goes contextual yeah yeah and
so it goes down to money muscles game
and frame
what is so so frame is basically
you're entering his frame and he's not
entering yours so frame in a way is
masculinity
i don't understand
um okay so if you work for somebody
it's
stepping into that yes yes versus him
stepping into so it's like leadership
for like holding frame is when you
when you like make fun of it so a way of
girls will do a [ __ ] test that's what
they call it is they'll make fun of a
guy a little bit and you want you don't
know this consciously but you're
watching to see how he reacts does he
make fun of you back does he kind of
like play into it or does he does he
like get offended and if he gets
offended that's him falling into your
frame
because he's missed yeah yeah because
he's thinking but we had to do this
historically because we had to make sure
the guy could protect us okay yeah and
so that's why if a guy kind of makes fun
of you like comes up to you and he's
like what's wrong with that you're like
like
you're kind of more interested right but
it's it's him because you're going into
his frame okay
and so and it's what the girl values so
like i i
was really involved in a church when i
lived in milwaukee and all the girls
there was relationship with god so they
wanted like that was the most alpha guy
they could get had the closest
relationship with god it was kind of
that's what i was thinking of when you
were talking about the different
communities was the guys there that got
all the girls probably would be viewed
as beta in the normal world but they but
they were getting the virgins
which which is the ideal right it's not
it's not like that's not funny i think i
think just to add to your point right
perception is everything from the
woman's standpoint if she perceives the
man
as an alpha then that's all that really
matters it doesn't matter if her friends
don't see him as a friend yeah it's all
about her so she would be alpha widowed
by that man because she perceived him as
an author
yeah and that the point comes down to
women actually want
men speaking
women actually want men better than them
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
man is better than them but she wants to
see him as better than her yeah i get
that yeah and so that's the problem with
girls with a bad boy past is because
oftentimes she doesn't she wants that
guy because hey hate and love are very
close but aren't these 20 that are
getting all the women bad boys
no not at all i wouldn't say all some
some are i mean so the baiters are in
the twenty percent or is it mean like
the alphas and they're getting all the
women and then the women are ruined and
then they're like oh we're gonna go to
the other eighty percent
i mean to be an alpha doesn't mean that
you're a bad boy like someone like for
example let's say [ __ ]
i don't know joe biden
yeah yeah i'd say my older brother's an
alpha but he's like really geeky
i think they'd kill him if they stream
themselves smash a pass show buy them
someone on twitter the other day was
like oh my gosh joe biden is such a good
looking man i would go to him and i
would move to him and someone was like
yeah i want my students loan paid off
too but that's not the way to do it
yeah but being think about it this way
because obviously you don't value money
in the same way but if you show joe
biden to like loads of girls from
venezuela who are from the slums
yeah i'm on it yeah but that wouldn't be
because i honestly i think everything
starts with looks
because i i think that if you want a
girl to genuinely desire you like you
have to be somewhat similar on the looks
level
yeah because if if a dude is like okay
if you if you
multi-millionaire tomorrow right or
let's say let's say fat guy right
multi-millionaire tomorrow he can get a
girl it's an eight nine or ten but she's
just with him for the money so it's not
like that genuine desire like like so a
lot of attraction's chemical so
women can women can smell a t-shirt and
see which guy they'd be the most
attracted to so it's
you know it's not it's not that genuine
desire i don't know you say that but it
all depends on
where skewed in terms of your brain of
thinking what you find attractive like
is the status the most attractive thing
to you is
the looks the most attractive thing to
you
it it all depends i couldn't say that
more women i think more women look at
looks than not because when you were
explaining it it made me think of
what show was it um
i don't think it was 90 day fiance it
was one of those shows the guy no no the
guy with no neck that oh he
he had money he had everything money
house the sat in the third and he got i
think it was 90 day fiance he got the
girl to come over from her country and
her country was um
low income and i can't remember where
she was from but if she
liked him off of just the financial
stuff and everything she would still be
with him but she wasn't attracted but
what i'd say did he have the alpha
traits though because people like dj
khaled and rick ross
they're not the guys in terms of in the
looks department but they have the alpha
traits and a lot of women dj khaled
yeah a lot of women
a lot of women would want dj khaled i
hear it i mean that's right that's why
it's four things it's money muscles
frame and game so i i think game is part
of it i do i do
you game
it's just how you play the game i think
game is partially a mindset it's it's
like the mindset if you don't give a
[ __ ] what she thinks you're gonna do
what you're gonna do like women find
that attractive i hate that but i love
that yeah you do
yeah like that's right if women if women
hated [ __ ] why why why are we
sleeping with them
like
like women complain a lot about [ __ ]
when there was there's a nice guy
there's a nice guy down the street
waiting
like i thought you hated them i thought
you hated them
what are you doing diane yeah because
you push the nice guy and then we'll go
over him and you can't respect him yeah
so that's game game is saying like like
not letting the woman walk all over you
and it's learning to build attraction
like i went to this pickup artist like
boot camp and then paid thousands of
dollars to learn how to get laid
thousands yeah did it work
no
sorry okay
no i think a couple guys took girls home
on the last night like one or two but
yeah if you guys want to watch that that
vlog is on my channel it's like i went
to a pickup artist boot camp you could
look it up
i think i think it would work for them
because remember they're not getting
creme de la creme they're just trying to
get any hole to put their penis in like
anything
like fat things but do you think you
have to practice in order to get good
with girls no but i think
the thing is some men learn fury and
that's why we've i've had black pickup
artists on our platform who have proper
theory ways
when now i've learned the theory like
reverse engineered it it's just a lot of
the techniques we were using were just
taught from on the block that mandem
would just teach us it wasn't like we
read a book it's just oh i see that
older man do this
i'm going to just copy it and just do it
i think that's a creme de la creme
like i know we're coming to the time i
mean like like
what if what if she's an ugly virgin an
ugly but oh then they don't care yeah
yeah they don't yeah
what about if she's a dumb pretty virgin
she's cool
doesn't matter
yeah because they yeah men that's what
kevin samuels would say yeah kevin
samuels would say it doesn't if a girl
was fat her virginity like didn't matter
to men because they they would just
think oh she couldn't get the sleep with
the guy like guys just didn't want to
sleep with her healthy and peel
it's
fit feminine friendly uh feminine
friendly youth
basically
so if they don't have those things then
my goodness
so right now go ahead
um
but for us what what do we get to go for
money muscles game and frame we want a
guy that's that makes a lot of money
that's strong like muscles are
attractive to us
game so that's basically being able to
build attraction and frame
so that's perhaps someone like future
that sierra went for and then
yeah i mean he's got yeah so if she went
for him it didn't work out because he's
because you can't lock bad boys down you
can't that's like tail as old as time
but she secured him
was she
no she didn't she did well well i mean
she got a child essentially
from from a reproduction point of view
she got yeah yeah so you're actually
correct that's a mating strategy so
women women get the genes from the guy
they want and then get the other guy to
take care of the kids
so wilson alpha alpha fox
yeah that's the one [ __ ] the alpha beta
but she's got her own money right it
doesn't matter it doesn't i don't um so
i'll explain
so my
the male and female dynamic is
my money is her money and her money is
her money
i say again so my money is her money
but her money is her money so she will
look at it from a standpoint of i will
get with a guy that i see of high status
but he's going to look after me and i'm
going to use my money on me
and even look at it this way like
jordan peterson talks about it is that
to make it to dumb it down you see these
high achieving corporate loyal females
do you think they're going to go date a
bartender even though they don't need
his money no cost not so there you go
well why should they
and that's what it goes down to beta
bucks well they they should sometimes
because men and women are valued for
different things so men don't care about
your money and there's only a small
percentage of men that make so if you
make six figures and you want a guy that
makes success you don't care about your
money if they have money
yeah yeah yeah
there's a huge percentage of the
population that don't have money so but
most women that have money don't want to
be with someone that doesn't yeah
someone doesn't have money
because then they'll be
more
masculine in a sense and they won't want
a feminine guy so indirectly that that
brokey's already written off essentially
yeah but she's not dating bro guys
but but a lot of girls think that's the
outcome that they're going to get but
sierra just gets to do that because
she's like a 9 10. would you give sierra
in her best years like i gave her ten
nine yeah yeah
she's up there
yeah so so ten like there's pretty
privilege but the average girl isn't
gonna get to do that the average girl's
just gonna end up by herself
unless she dates an average guy but the
problem is a lot of women think that
they're above average guys
a lot of women would be happier with
average guys yeah i feel like that's the
case like you you generally tend to
stick within
your class your earning potential no not
modern modern women though i don't know
i don't know
well fifty percent of women are over
thirty or single in child or fifty
percent of women that hit thirty year
single and childless
i mean
so in a way yeah so in a way it's like
why you're you're a pretty girl there's
a lot of guys i'm sure that would be
willing to marry you but yeah yeah it's
not like i couldn't have been married at
this point but it's never been right
yeah but that's that's because because
yeah because you want you want better oh
yeah yeah like i want to be happy with
someone not just settle for them because
they're offering me security
so which is awful i know i should be
like so you're exactly what we're
talking about
i should be like devoted and
self-sacrificing i'm not
do you so
would you rather end up by yourself or
with a guy that maybe you're not as
attracted to and maybe doesn't have some
of the things that you're looking for so
you're 50. you look back in your life i
don't think i'll be alone when i'm 50 i
don't i don't i wouldn't have no i'm
asking if you had to pick one of the two
i know you don't i would rather be your
own than with someone that i wasn't
happy with yeah and so and so that's
that's what's happening is because
because that's that's what most girls
say
i had my daughter when i was 18 and and
uh her father was 21
um
it didn't work out obviously we were
very young we would turned up very
different people
and so i've raised her alone so i do
understand what it is to
to be alone with a child and what you
have to do and what you have to go
through
but i have had relationships where i
could have
settled down got married and started and
like
extended my family
but i've chosen not to
for many different reasons i don't think
it's because they weren't alpha
it could be my personal circumstances
who i am as a person i don't think i
just i find sometimes the context of of
this
too
simplified but
in a way they had something they didn't
have something you wanted because if a
guy had everything that you wanted you
would marry him oh yeah yeah and so so
in a way you didn't think they were good
enough oh yeah absolutely and and so
that's that's the point i'm not yeah
it's like you keep searching for better
and sometimes it's like the better is
not out for one thing about
not even just women for men if you find
the right person no matter you will make
yourself ready regardless man or woman
you're making yourself what is the right
person
depends on the person
i mean whatever you want it to be right
there there you go
there you go so the right person i have
that too
it's not
i need to pick a man because i'm like so
desperate to have that thing
but it's the same for a man he needs to
find the right woman for him and that is
that is very personal well i don't i
don't think there's one right person and
i think that mindset is kind of why
everyone's so single because because we
keep thinking we're gonna do better but
but it's really like there's always
gonna be risk in life and you're not
going to get everything that you want so
it's just picking someone who's a good
bet yeah i agree i'm sorry you said
about why do we need to find that one
right person obviously now you've had
you had your child let's say you were
childless if you wanna if you want to
have a child
majority of women they actually have to
find their person before yeah
also um
the difference between men and women you
said that our men have to pick their
partners by a certain time
men's value as they get older
appreciates
in the dating market
women's value depreciates in the date in
market so you think that's outdated
in terms of women are now educated they
can earn more like in terms of what we
know about fertility women are so a lot
longer than what we used to think it
used to be like 30 was our peak now it's
it's that's not true so so 90 of your
eggs are gone by 30 and most women
actually can't afford in vitro
fertilization it's about 20 to 25 000
and it might not even work
so
and and
actually women are having more fertility
issues now because we're in worse shape
we're less healthy than we've ever been
what about men
men can have kids up into their 50s i i
do think there is a slight sperm yeah
that decreases around true
but maybe 35 i think yeah but but the
difference is men can still be fathers
in their 50s a woman after 35 it's tough
by 40 she is like a 15 10 chance of
getting pregnant do you want to be if
you're that age anyway and so it's not
outdated at some point the party stops
and the question is is when and some
girls get get more like some girls get
more than others
i probably should stop a bit earlier for
women
like
if we're doing
i don't want to say all men
i'm not doing the work but if women are
doing the majority of the child rearing
it should eventually because you don't
want to get to 50 and be like okay now
i'm going gonna be a single parent for
the next 20 years
you know
so if you're 35 and you have a kid and
you have to raise it for 18 it's a lot
it's it's it's easier when you're
younger yeah
no it is
so perhaps we should get fifty percent
yeah wait why
well if we're doing most of the child
rearing
it's
financially it's it's the basically but
maybe they pay child support maybe they
don't it's the lowest end skill in terms
of for a man to provide for a family so
many people can't even provide for
themselves and so many people within
the uk will live below the poverty line
so to be able to provide for a whole
family you're probably in the top five
to ten percent of of men in order to
raise a child like pretty much any
person can raise a child
right okay
so so which one's the more valuable
skill is what i ask you be able to
provide for a family will be able to
raise a family because so many people
can raise provide for a family of course
but that then leaves a very small
percentage of men that are attractive
and it takes away the alpha status
surely it's just the ones with more
money well in terms of who who can
provide yeah who you're going to pick
because if if an alpha is an alpha
because he's got
game frame
the other ones but he doesn't have the
money
you're going to go for him perhaps
because he's more attractive to you but
you're going to realize quickly actually
he's not in the five percent so let me
go for a beta
so and then if he doesn't have the the
money then what you're saying about in
terms of the woman would do most of the
children it wouldn't be more of a
50-foot split
it's not like if he chooses to provide
and so but the point is it's it's
incentivizing women to make bad
decisions because you're paid to do it
i i mean i've i've heard i've heard
girls say that they literally had a kid
to get government from oh yeah hard
and that's that's a horrible way to
bring a child into the world no no yeah
it's it's too easy to have a kid here
yeah
and so even or you get money from the
guy
it's like why we can get jobs we can
work and it should be fun i think most
women do i don't i don't know any women
that don't go to work
but but they're they're then why are
they having kids to get money they're
married and and like these are older
generations too like it's not just me
i'm talking about but like i've got
plenty of friends that are married like
i'm talking my mother's generation
older generations like my grandma my oma
there
they all worked i don't know any women
that are just like i'm staying home no i
i agree like i think women should work
but the incentive like i i think if you
have a kid and it was someone it doesn't
work out it should just be 50 50 custody
no child support
do you know all men like uh
like co-parents that pay all of their
child support like is that an experience
you all have
do you know i know yeah yeah i know i
know a couple from where i'm from that
got like screwed in a divorce and a lot
like they've been working for 20 years
built up something and then lost all of
it wow and that that's like takes the
soul out of a dude
[Music]
and when and when guys have to sign up
for a contract that is a 50 failure rate
and if they fail they loot they could
lose half their stuff a lot of guys
don't want to get married anymore
and it hurts us because like we're
trying to get ranks at least i am
you know
ring by spring
oh god
stop
but um this was actually really
interesting conversation um
it's interesting to hear from you
because you're you're south african you
said wow that's interesting okay that's
what i love about london is i can talk
to so many people that are like
literally from all over the world in
like one room
um but i am going to read the final
super chats and then close out the show
um because i'm trying to get you guys
home before the train
so
zayceon 12. um i wait let me refresh the
page real quick guys like the video
while you're at it let's get to a
thousand likes in here there's 2 000
people watching right now and there's
only
less than a thousand likes the audacity
of some of you stop it stop it stop it
like the video i'm a florent i'm simping
hard for the girl with the glasses and i
haven't heard her say a word
they're real they love you in this chat
they love you the real um
the real cesmo no such thing as the
right person especially for a man you
have to mold to the person you are with
it into the partner for you a me and
dana can't stop nobody can't nobody stop
the juice so tell me what's the use i
think is it better it's better to find
that to have all the fun life is about
choices choose your experiences wisely
just saying the real cease-mothers
already instances of young boys mothers
only fans being discovered by their
classmates two well-known content
creators have had young men message them
and tell them they contemplated suicide
due to the endless bullying zach payne
alpha isn't just about money he could be
alpha and the blues guitar poor but why
is she dating him alpha there is their
competence domain chef paul supporting
the show show thank you depos 4735 jess
has come a long way in her femininity
when i first saw her on the show she was
a bit manish and
and no wow the longer hair the legs the
shorts
thanks
i'm off i'm feminine
like we're basketball players we come a
long way quick look
um okay ranch hater thank you guys for
the content blonde girl is stunning and
i hope everyone's day is going wow you
hear that there's something there's
something um the uk economist um please
ask what type of men do they qualify for
income wise zen i am quite sure of
twerking is let me just refresh it and
make sure i didn't miss any but i think
i got them all so um why don't we go
around everyone say any final thoughts
you had anything
anything you want to say speak your
truth so very quickly they said
something about content creator what was
the thing about they killed killed
himself or bullying or something oh just
um there was people that messaged a
content creator saying that they um were
bullied for their moms only fans
that's quite sad
[Music]
huh
go ahead if you want to say your final
thoughts um
stay away from the slags um
make sure you bet properly
and if you want to hear us talk again
follow the domino effect podcast so it's
tagged in the description always cause
habit there's a special special episode
of pearls on there
and um you don't actually have to
subscribe to patreon to watch it so go
go over and plug yourself
um thank you for having me i had a
really good time
like and subscribe
um i would say that it's always lovely
to hear from different people and what
they think especially from different
cultures and different environments so
yeah always enjoy
like having me here yeah thank you for
coming yeah um i want to say i feel a
bit sorry for russell wilson especially
considering future's such a public
figure
um but i guess if he's happy he's happy
so at the end of the day go where you're
wanted as men and i'll focus on yourself
um final thoughts yeah
just remember
that when you
get into a relationship or when you get
married and have children that you're
not just representing yourself anymore
you're representing the whole family
same for a husband as well and um i
enjoyed being on the show and thank you
for saying i'm more feminine
[Applause]
i have got some final thoughts um i
don't feel sorry for russell wilson
um i'm just gonna put this out there
um i think he's putting on himself
i do
empathize with him in this sense that he
had his eyes or wall pulled over his
eyes but i've seen instances where
she's disrespected him in so many
different regards and
at that moment it's like you you picked
your poison so it is what it is
okay guys um just a reminder some final
announcements follow our clips channel
guys i really want to get to a thousand
subs i think we're at like 500 now so
get us to a thousand subs like the video
on your way out liking is the most
important metric that youtube uses to
push us in the algorithm so make sure
you like it our members only live stream
is next week organized by our girl jess
yes
[Music]
so if you guys want to see us eat some
pizza after show after the show sign up
for our memberships it's only five bucks
a month guys um
my ig is just dot pearly thanks you
gonna put your ig in jess tell him to
follow you
my ig is it's dot ya dot girl underscore
jess
um also subscribe to the channel we're
maybe trying to get to 250 i don't you
know don't subscribe i mean we're trying
to get to 250 but quarter million
quite a bit slower
also guys um all the donations thank you
so much i'm so grateful for each and
every one of you i know a ton of you
watch for free which is fine you know i
put it on for all of you but i also
really appreciate when people send
donations because it helps us do
upgrades in the studio
and shout out to our member of the week
which is chris you even donated today in
the chat let's go chris
um don't forget to subscribe on your way
out like the video and we will talk to
you next time
and that's a wrap you sure
100 yeah
we're not making that mistake we made
yesterday we gave him some best bits
yesterday
[Music]